hallo herzlich willkommen in meine
torten will heute gibt's bei mir himba
muffins mit weiße schokolade und im
innern der muffins habe ich so ein
kleines herzchen drin und wenn man die
machen dann später auf schneidet habe
man quasi so ein rotes herz in muffins
tag mit drin
die eignen sich natürlich wieder ideal
für den valentinstag oder für den
muttertag oder jahrestag oder
hochzeitstag wie auch immer und die
zutaten darf so zeige ich euch jetzt für
den hessentag braucht ihr 160 gramm
zucker 100 gramm joghurt 50 gramm öl das
sind 60 milliliter 150 gramm mehl und
ein teelöffel backpulver und ich brauche
jetzt noch rote lebensmittelfarbe zuerst
geht jetzt dass ihr euere rührschüssel
und vermischt es ganz kurz mit schnee
kommt dass ich dazu und es wird auch
kurz verrührt jetzt kommen eigentlich
alle zutaten nacheinander dazu
wenn der teig zu feststellt dann gebt
ihr einfach noch 1 2 esslöffel joghurt
mit dazu und wir werden die herzchen
roth deswegen kommt jetzt noch etwas
rote lebensmittelfarbe dazu
den teig gebt ihr dann auf ein mit
backpapier ausgelegtes backblech oder
auf dem bug horst und streicht es schön
glatt auf
das theoretisch auch in einer großen
springform machen
der teig wird jetzt bei 180 grad etwa
zehn bis vierzehn minuten gebacken
vergessen auf keinen fall die stäbchen
probe nach dem backen sie datei jetzt so
aus den zieht ihr jetzt vom backblech
runter und lässt ihn vom backpapier
unternehmen der euch eine herzform und
die muss von der größe her in dieses
muffin blick rein passen also sie darf
in kleinsten rausgucken aber minute und
außerdem sticht ihr jetzt die kleinen
herzchen aus
für den muffin strike braucht ihr dann
zwei eier 120 gramm zucker 200 gramm
joghurt 100 gramm öl das sind 120
milliliter dann braucht ihr 300 gramm
mehl und zwei teelöffel backpulver und
100 gramm weiße kuvertüre die müsste
dann hacken und ihr braucht noch
himbeeren und entscheidet selbst wie
viele ihr davon nimmt während der
zubereitung stände die aber noch so
lange in die kühltruhe und der zeigt wie
das genauso gemacht wie der teig eben
deswegen zeigen gibt es mal im
schnelldurchlauf
gibt es da noch die gehackte kuvertüre
mit rein und mischt sie einfach in den
tag
mafffin form und legt da schon mal die
bafin papier förmchen rein und da kommt
jetzt etwa ein halber esslöffel hinein
verteilt sind haltung zum islam
mafffin boden dann nehmt ihr euch die
herzchen und die sind jetzt nur
zweidimensional das heißt die seite hat
die herzform und die seite ist flach und
jetzt müsst ihr euch immer merken steckt
die herzchen jetzt am besten mit der
vorderseite zu euch in den teig bis auf
den boden ziemlich mittig
und dann holt ihr jetzt erst die
himbeeren aus dem gefrierfach und
krümelt da jetzt jeweils noch eine
himbeere außen rum
es geht ganz gut wenn sie noch ganz tief
gebräunt sind und wenn ihr das rezept
ohne das herz in der mitte macht könnt
ihr einfach anstatt des herzens eine
himbeere reinstecken
und dann fühlte die mav in form mit ihr
aus einem esslöffel vom teig noch auf
einfach oben drüber und aufpassen dass
das herz nicht umkippt
und jetzt könnt ihr nochmal eine
himbeere ganz oben drauf
die lange 280 grad etwa 25 bis 30
minuten gebacken den restlichen teig
haben jetzt noch ihren herzlichen
ausgestochen
die können nämlich ganz gut einfühlen
und das nächste mal dann benutzen
und hier habe ich noch etwas zeit übrig
gehabt da hab ich jetzt einfach eine
kleine springform genommen und noch ein
paar herzliche reingesteckt und den teig
müsst ihr auch nicht wegschmeißen den
könnte zerbröseln und zum beispiel zur
kickbox verarbeiten denn könnt ihr
nämlich auch zerbröselt ganz gut
einfrieren oder macht einfach so ein
quatsch schichten und gebt da die reste
hinein und außerdem müsst ihr noch 100
gramm weiße kuvertüre hacken und
vorbereiten das kommt nämlich direkt auf
die muffins wenn sie heiß auf dem aus
dem ofen rauskommen und dann schmilzt es
schön an der oberfläche und das ist
sozusagen dann schon das topping und
dann sind auch fertig die muffins frisch
aus dem ofen rausgekommen und ihr müsst
jetzt schnell aus der form rausholen
jetzt müsste aber aufpassen eure
herzchen die liegen jetzt quasi so drin
und ihr müsst sie auch später so
aufschneiden dass ihr das herz dann
später seht weil wir so schneidezähne
kein herz und merkt euch einfach die
richtung als einfach so raus nehmen und
praktisch so dann auch auf ein blech
setzen auf mehr küchen rasens nicht
drehen
und jetzt müsst ihr die weiße kovac
einfach oben drauf platz sehen und durch
die restliche wärme schmilzt die jetzt
etwas und wird dann oben fest wenn euch
das zu süß wird könnt ihr direkt lassen
aber eigentlich der tecnet so axel
durch einen zahnstocher und markiert wie
man später die muffins schneiden muss
dass man das herz sieht also bei mir
sitzen ja die herzchen so also muss ich
auch so eine markierung setzen
ihr könnt auch zum beispiel zucker
streusel darauf streuen in einer linie
und dann sieht man auch so wie man
später die muffins anschneiden muss
jetzt abkühlen und fest werden
die muffins sind unglaublich lecker und
auch schön fruchtig und saftig aber ich
muss jetzt im nachhinein ehrlich schon
sagen dass dieser tag etwas zu fest ist
für dieses muster erwähnen
das heißt ihr könnt zum beispiel auch
den buttermilch tag nehmen den habe ich
euch schon mal vor ein paar monaten also
ganz am anfang von der video zeit
vorgestellt
das video hieß buttermilch muffins mit
mascarpone topping und dieser muffins
tages dort etwas flüssiger und eignet
sich wahrscheinlich besser um dieses
herz drum runden auszufüllen
denn dieser feste teig hat die das herz
und bisher drückt und entscheidet darauf
für euch selbst also ich finde die
schmecken auch so ganz gut und sehen
super aus
und dann wünsche ich euch schon mal viel
spaß beim nachmachen lassen auf jeden
fall einen kommentar da und ich freue
mich schon auf eure fotos und auf euer
feedback bis zum nächsten mal tschüss
scheiße ich bin so blöd man nächstes
passiert habe ich meistens nur wie die
herzchen sind ich dachte jetzt gerade
draußen immer was ich dachte ich dachte
jetzt da draußen weil du musst dies so
schneider zum schwätzen ach so ist es
schlimm wenn man es halt bei den
restlichen rückgängig und schreiben
du merkst du halt die äußere